[Música]
Olá, minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam
muito bem-vindos para a nossa live
semanal dos apoiadores
da comunidade fechada do YouTube, Dr.
Alan Dutra. Boa noite, Cristina Caru. À
medida que vocês forem entrando, por
favor, coloque o seu nome, de onde você
fala, se vocês estão me escutando bem,
se estamos aí com bom áudio, o microfone
tá captando direito
e vamos iniciar já as perguntas. Temos
bastante perguntas hoje. Vamos tentar
não atrasar, não vai dar pra gente
discutir nenhum artigo específico porque
é bastante pergunta que acumulou. Boa
noite, Marlon. Seja muito bem-vindo à
nossa comunidade.
E vamos iniciar. Então, eh agora tô com
sistema novo aqui. Eu vou apresentar
para vocês
as perguntas. Algumas perguntas eu não
vou
a ler ela inteira, tá? Porque tem
algumas perguntas aí que tem uns
errinhos de português, de gramática,
então fica chato de ler. Mas vamos lá. O
uso de peptídeos injetáveis para fins de
performance esportiva é seguro ou
apresenta colaterais como uso de
anabolizantes? Já temos estudos o
suficiente?
Resposta rápida é que não temos estudos
suficientes.
E é uma excelente pergunta essa daí, né?
Os peptídeos injetáveis no Brasil, a
maioria deles não está não estão
disponíveis. E a gente tinha alguns
pepetídos via oral, só que eles saíram
do mercado mais ou menos 2 anos, né?
Então a visa proibiu
bem, primeira coisa que eu queria falar
para vocês, peptídeos não são
anabolizantes esteroides, são moléculas
completamente diferentes, tanto na
estrutura quanto no mecanismo de ação.
Enquanto que os esteroides anabólicos,
o, enquanto os esteroides anabolizantes
anabólicos são derivados sintéticos de
testosterona e se ligam diretamente aos
receptores androgênicos e substituem
assim os hormônios naturais. Os
peptídios são carteias curtas de
aminoácidos que funcionam como
sinalizadores
biológicos. são estimula o seu próprio
corpo a produzir mais hormônio do
crescimento e GF1 ou outros fatores
anabólicos.
Em relação segurança, os dados mais
recentes de 2024 e 25 mostram que os
peptídeos são consideravelmente mais
seguros, sim que os anabolizantes. Os
efeitos colaterais mais comuns são
vermelhidão no local da injeção, fadiga,
aumento do apetite, retenção hídrica.
Então, os esteroides têm aí um risco
muito maior como supressão do eixo
hormonal, ginecomastia,
hepatotoxicidade,
problemas cardiovasculares graves e
alterações psicológicas.
Porém, contudo, todavia, precisamos ser
honestos sobre o estado da arte da
ciência, né? A maioria dos peptídeos
para performance, no caso do BP17
e outras siglas aí como CJC 1295 e os
GHRPS
carece muito ainda de estudos clínicos
robustos em humanos.
Tem bastante dados aí em modelos
animais, alguns estudos fase dois, mas
faltam trials, né, estudos grandes de
longo prazo. O BPC 157 tá banido pela
UADA, né, que é aquela associação
internacional aí de antidoping desde
2022,
justamente pela falta de dados de
segurança adequados e tem a minha vida
de apenas 30 minutos, o que torna até
mesmo a detecção difícil.
O que nós sabemos com mais certeza vem
dos peptídios GLP1 que tem aprovação da
FDE, estudos extensivos mostrando
segurança quando usados de forma
adequada. Já os peptídeos como CJC15
com DAC podem elevar o GH por 6 a 10
dias com uma única injeção, aumentando o
GF1 por até 11 dias.
Então, tem uma potência bastante
significativa.
A minha opinião pessoal, profissional, é
que os peptídeos representam uma
alternativa bem mais segura do que os
esteroides anabolizantes, já que se a
pessoa for utilizar, né, não deveria
utilizar nada, mas se fosse utilizar, aí
os peptídos são com certeza mais
seguros, mas não são isentos de risco,
certo? Sabemos disso. A qualidade da
fonte é crítica. Isso é um problema,
porque os produtos que estão no mercado,
a maior parte é de fontes aí
alternativas e vários são contaminados
ou subdosados.
E a falta de regulamentação
significa que a pessoa que tá comprando
está correndo um grande risco aí, tanto
do ponto de vista legal quanto de
qualidade do produto.
Para fim de performance esportiva, é
melhor não utilizar.
E alguns peptídeos podem ser usados com
relativa segurança
se forem sob supervisão adequada. que no
Brasil não temos essa opção porque foram
proibidos aí pela Anvisa
e sempre dentro de um contexto de
otimização hormonal global, OK?
E se a pessoa for competir e qualquer
esporte olímpico ou profissional não
pode utilizar os peptídeos por causa que
esses compostos estão na lista proibida
da UDA, pelo menos a maioria. Bem, vamos
paraa segunda pergunta.
Colocar como respondida. Próxima. A
modulação hormonal bioidêntica
em mulheres apenas é arriscada em caso
de risco de trombose,
câncer de mama úterovários ou tem riscos
em outros casos?
Apesar de que eu já ter tocado no
assunto antes, poderia aprofundar um
pouco mais sobre os riscos gerais, exame
de monitoramento.
Então, os riscos principais você apontou
trombose, câncer de mama, câncer de
útero, principalmente de endométrio, né,
e ovários. Mas a literatura recente
mostra que existem outras considerações
importantes que precisamos avaliar.
Primeiro,
eu preciso enfatizar que quando uso
progesterona micronizada bioidêntica e
estradiol transdérmico nos meus
pacientes, os riscos são muito menores,
são significativamente menores, mas não
são zero comparados aos hormônios
sintéticos. Os estudos franceses
recentes do E3N,
com mais de 54.000 Mulheres demonstraram
que a combinação de estradiol
transdêmico pela pele, sempre estradiol
sempre na pele ou na mucosa com a
progesterona natural não aumentou o
risco de câncer de mama em 8 anos de
acompanhamento
diferente das progestinas sintéticas.
Sobre os outros riscos, além do que você
mencionou, riscos no fígado hepáticos,
né? Eles são praticamente eliminados com
a via transdérmica, já que nós evitamos
a primeira passagem.
Então, por isso que tem que ser
utilizado
o transdêmico ou transvaginal ou até
mesmo
pode utilizar sublingual em alguns
casos.
Especialmente
mulheres têm histórico de doença
hepática ou metabolismo alterado. Doença
da vesícula biliar, né, é outro risco
que tem que ser considerado. Ele pode
aumentar se for utilizar o estrogênio
oral, que eu não recomendo,
e a via transdâmica praticamente elimina
esse problema.
Então, mulheres com histórico de pedra
na vesícula, cálculos biliares, devem
sempre utilizar a via transdâmica.
alterações metabólicas, no caso da
resistência sulínica, né, o pré-diabetes
e modificações do perfil lipídico, são
muito menos prováveis com hormônios
bioidênticos,
especialmente em progesterona
micronizada, que tem efeito neutro até
benéfico no metabolismo de glicose e
lipídios,
diferente das progestinas que podem
induzir resistência insulínica.
Pressão alta pode acontecer com algumas
formulações orais, mas a via transdâmica
geralmente não afeta a pressão arterial.
Então o estradiol transdérêmico, na
verdade pode até melhorar a função de
atelial e ajudar a controlar pressão
arterial. Enxaqueca, algumas mulheres
têm enxaqueca.
Então, mulheres que têm essa situação, a
enchaque com aura devem evitar o
estrogênio oral e podem usar o transd
e o monitoramento é função hepática, né,
que são exames TJ,GP, bilirubinas,
perfil lipídico completo, gama GT,
glicemia, insulina de jejum, hormônios
tiroidianos, ferritina, vitamina D,
homocisteína, marcadores inflamatórios
com proteína ser reativa
e os hormônios basais como estradiol FSH
LH progesterona, testosterona total e
livre e o DHA sulfatado
para avaliação de risco trombótico em
casos específicos, né? Então a gente
pode pedir aí o perfil de trombose, que
é a proteína S, a proteína C,
antitombrina 3, mutação do fator 5 de
Liiden quando tem histórico familiar ou
histórico pessoal de ter tido trombose
antes. E durante o tratamento, o
protocolo envolve revisão clínica de em
3s meses, né, inicialmente, depois a
cada 6 meses e nos exames de
acompanhamento sempre verificar os
níveis hormonais, a função hepática,
perfil lipídico a cada 6 meses. E para
monitoramento específico é importante
também mamografia anual, especialmente
após 40 anos de idade. Ultrafom pélvico
para avaliar a espessura do endométrico,
pode ficar com uma espessura aumentada,
né, com hiperplasia
por conta dos hormônios. Ela tem que tá
menos que 5 mm. A densitometria óssea a
cada do anos, importante para ver se não
tem osteoporose.
E o teste saliverado para hormônios
esteroides, né, que está usando
transdêmico, pode ser bastante útil
porque vai refletir melhor os níveis
teciduais do que o exame de sangue. E os
os testes também de metabólitos
urinários, que é o Dutch Test, é muito
bom para avaliar o metabolismo hormonal,
especialmente do estrogênio, para saber
se não tá indo para um caminho errado,
né, que pode aumentar o risco do câncer
de mama ou de ovário ou de endométrio.
Então a gente tem que ver se o
estrogênio tá sendo metabolizado
corretamente pela via segura, né, de
dois hidroxilação com metilação, ao
invés de pro caminho do 16 hidróx ou
quatro hidróxos
riscos de câncer.
Então, precisamos ajustar as doses
baseadas nos sintomas e também nos
exames laboratoriais, mas os sintomas
são mais importantes. E o objetivo não é
atingir os níveis iguais de uma mulher
de 25 anos, mas os níveis fisiológicos
adequados para alívio sintomático.
Certo? Vamos paraa próxima pergunta
aqui. Pessoal, eu vou pedir para vocês
evitarem de mandar pergunta ao vivo
hoje, porque tem muita pergunta, acho
que não vai dar tempo, tá?
Próxima pergunta. Então, essa aqui já
foi respondida. Próxima.
Estou tratando disbiose
e uma das bactérias que deu alta no
exame foi Metano Brevibacter Smith.
Tomei antibiótico, estou na dieta loufa
de map, estou com alguns sintomas
novamente. Prata coloidal seria uma boa
opção. Problema da prata colocar que tem
pouco estudo, tá? E com relação ao óleo
de orégano, então esse metano breve
bacterism é um marquea, né? é um tipo de
bactéria
do intestino e é um dos patógenos mais
desafiadores no tratamento da questão do
cibo, né, que é super crescimento
bacteriano, especialmente dos tipos
bacterianos que produzem mais metano.
Então, ó de orégano, sim, é uma escolha
boa porque ele é bom para esse tipo de
cibo pulmetano. Tem estudos recentes
202425 que mostram que o óleo de
orégano, especialmente os produtos
padronizados com carvacrol 70%, tem uma
eficácia comparável a rifaximina que é
um antibiótico padrão aí
em relação a bons resultados.
E aí o problema da refaxemina que é caro
e tem muita recidiva, né?
Então, aituratura mostra taxa de
resposta de 46% com os herbais versus
34% com a refaximina sozinha.
Então, para essa bactéria específica,
200 mg de óleo de orégano emulsificado
três vezes ao dia, pode ser uma boa por
4 semanas.
Quanto a plata colidal eu comentei, né?
não tem estudo suficiente para isso.
As pesquisas mais recentes de 20242
mostram que a prata coloidal não teve
eficácia específica para arqueias, como
é o caso do desse caso aí do metano
bacterism e pode causar disbiose
adicional ao microbioma. Então, estudos
e modelos animais indicam que mesmo
doses elevadas de nanopartículas de
prata não alteraram significativamente
as comunidades bacterianas, microbianas,
intestinais. Nesse caso,
então, voltando, óleo de orégano, como
eu comentei, é uma boa. Você pode usar
também alicina, que é o extrato de alho,
né, com esse princípio ativo. No caso,
extrato de alho 450 mg duas vezes ao
dia. Colocar um disuptor de biofilme,
que é o NAC, 600 mg duas vezes ao dia
para ajudar o tratamento. e considerar a
berberina também, que é muito boa, três
vezes ao dia em rotação com orégano.
E após 3 meses de lowfod de map, pode
começar a reproduzir gradualmente os
alimentos sementáveis.
O PHG, né, que é o é a goma guar
parcialmente hidrolizada, é uma opção 5
g ao dia. É um prébiótico fibra que não
alimenta o o metanobacter SMF. E pode
entrar também com procinético natural,
como o caso do gengibre, né, que é o
nome comercial no Brasil é o
que eu que eu mais utilizado é o
E fugiu o nome agora, daqui a pouco eu
lembro.
Então, lembrar que a recorrência é comum
com Mctanobacter Smith, que ele forma
biofilmes existentes,
por isso a importância dos biofilme, né,
como é o caso do NAC, e a rotação dos
antimicrobianos naturais a cada quatro
semanas para não ter resistência.
Vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Foi isso aqui. É, tá certo.
Qual que é minha opinião sobre o comer
ovos todos os dias de dois a quatro?
Acho ótimo comer ovo. Como bastante ovo.
Eu não vejo nenhum problema de comer
essa quantidade. Eu como entre quatro a
oito ovos por dia. Eu considero essa
prática benéfica paraa maioria das
pessoas.
Tem um estudo que saiu em 2025 agora
esse ano no American Journal of Clinical
Nutrition que mostrou que a gordura
saturada
e não o colesterol dietético dos ovos,
né? É que vai dar problema no LDL. OK?
Eu já não concordo muito com essa
história da gordura saturada ser vilã,
mas eu tô aqui para vocês relatando esse
estudo aí que saiu. Então não tem tanta
significância assim um colesterol do
ovo, tá? Esse colesterol que você
ingere, ele faz pouca diferença, porque
o organismo fabrica a maior parte do
colesterol do nosso organismo.
Quando compararam pessoas consumindo
dois ovos por dia numa dieta baixa de
gorduras saturadas, o LDL até diminuiu
em comparação com quem comia apenas um
ovo por semana numa dieta rica em
gordura saturada nesse estudo, tá? Outro
ponto fundamental que sempre explico é
que quando você consome ovos, sim, pode
haver um pequeno aumento do LDL total,
mas isso é irrelevante se você
considerar que a grande maioria é
produzido no organismo.
E mas aí o ponto crucial, esse aumenta
principalmente as custas das partículas
grandes e flutuantes do LDL, que são as
partículas que não dão problema na
parede da artéria, não são aterogênicas.
Então, as partículas que vão dar
problema na artéria são as partículas de
EDL, pequenas e densas, OK? Lembra de
bolinha de good, essa é a problemática.
E a bola de praia não é. Então, LDL bola
de praia, grande, fofa, grande e
flutuante, essa partícula não vai
danificar o endotélio.
Então, as partículas grandes têm um
risco cardiovascular bem menor em
relação às pequenas e densas.
Teve um estudo que saiu no Journal of
Nutrition que mostrou que o consumo de
dois a três ovos por dia não só melhorou
a função da HDL, olha só, aumentou a
função da HDL, que é bem mais importante
que a concentração, como também aumentou
de 20 a 31% dos níveis de luteína e
ziachentina no plasma, que são
excelentes antioxidantes, né, inclusive
muito bons para função da retina, né,
dos óleos.
Esses carotenoides, né, são
antioxidantes potentes que protegem
contra a oxidação do LDL.
E tem pesquisas recentes da Universidade
de Monach, publicadas nesse ano também,
que mostraram que doses que consumiam
ovos de uma a seis vezes por semana
tiveram 29% menos risco de morte por
doença cardiovascular, comparado aos que
raramente comiam ovos. Isso mesmo entre
pessoas que tinham dislipidemia.
Então, os ovos são excelente fonte de
várias vitaminas e minerais. Já falamos
da zeachantina, da luteína, mas também
são fontes muito importantes de colina,
que é importante paraa função cerebral e
metilação.
Também são fontes de vitamina D,
selênium, proteína de altíssima
qualidade biológica.
Então, basa na literatura e, na minha
opinião, experiência clínica, se você
comer dois a quatro ovos por dia,
especialmente caipiras, orgânicos, isso
é perfeitamente seguro e benéfico. É
muito melhor que ficar comendo pão três
vezes por dia, tá? Desde que você tenha
uma dieta equilibrada, evitando o
excesso de junk food, evitando o excesso
de alimentos processados,
industrializados.
E o problema nunca foi o ovo em si, OK?
E claro, sempre evitando glúten e
laticínios convencionais, que são mais
problemáticos para cardiovascular, são
mais inflamatórios do que os ovos jamais
serão.
Aqui tá relacionada uma pergunta
relacionada. Ouvo é indicado para quem
tem pissoris e não vejo nenhum problema
de quem tem pissoris comer ovo, tá? Não
tem nada aí que
realmente fale contra.
Vamos pra próxima.
É dito que o carcinoma base do celular
aparece devido à exposição ao sol, mas
na medicina integrativa se sabe que o
sol não é maléfico. Depende. Vamos
discutir sobre isso. Inclusive é dito
pelo Tolair que esse tipo de carcinoma
aparece mais em pessoas não expostas ao
sol do que em pessoas expostas como
pescadores, por exemplo. Então, qual
seria a razão do aparecimento desse
carcinoma? Veja bem, existe uma
diferença muito grande entre pessoas que
se expõem ao sol de maneira exagerada
nas férias e que durante a maior parte
do ano fica escondido do sol e um
pescador que todo santo dia se expõe ao
sol, tá? Tem uma diferença muito grande,
tá?
Então, continuando,
a literatura recente que eu acabei de
revisar sobre esse assunto confirma
pelo menos quase tudo que toi Ribeiro
tem ensinado há anos. Paradoxalmente,
múltiplos estudos mostram que pessoas
com deficiência de vitamina D tm maior
incidência de carcinôm base celular. E
quando suplementamos vitamina D nesses
pacientes, as taxas de recorrência
diminuem de forma significativa. Então,
o estudo que foi publicado em 2019
mostrou que após suplementação adequada
de vitamina D, a recorrência do cional
base celular caiu para apenas 3,5%.
Então, na minha visão, baseada na
medicina funcional, existe três fatores
principais. Primeiro, deficiência
crônica de vitamina D, que é um grande
de epidemia pelo estilo de vida moderno,
predominantemente indoor.
Isso criou uma epidemia de
hipovitaminose D. Então, a vitamina D
tem propriedades antiproliferativas,
propoptóticas,
ajudam nas células da pele e quando
estamos deficiente de vitamina D,
perdemos a proteção natural. Então,
estudos mostram que o receptor de
vitamina D está presente nas células do
carcinoma base celular.
E a sua ativação adequada inibe a via de
sinalização, que é fundamental para o
desenvolvimento desse tumor. Segundo,
diz função mitocondrial que hoje é
extremamente comum, estresse oxidativo.
Então o câncer, incluindo o carcinom
base celular, pode ser visto como uma
doença metabólica mitocondrial e não é
primariamente genética. Então, quando as
mitocôndrias não funcionam
adequadamente, a produção excessiva de
espécie reativa de oxigênio criando um
ambiente celular propício para
transformações malignas. Então, a
deficiência de zinco, selena e outros
cofatores mitocondriais pode piorar esse
quadro. Terceiro ponto, desequilíbrio
dos sistemas antioxidantes. Pessoas que
têm o cinoma base celular frequentemente
apresenta níveis inadequados de
antioxidantes como gluta vitamina C,
vitamina E, carotenoides e selênio. E
sem esses protetores naturais, o DNA
fica mais vulnerável a lesões, não
apenas a radiação travioleta, mas também
ao estresse que está ativo de várias
outras fontes. E aí aquela história, os
pesquisadores
interessados nesse assunto
verificaram que os pescadores e
agricultores
que são expostos cronicamente
cronicamente continualmente ao sol tem
sim menor incidência de base celular do
que trabalho de escritório. Por quê?
Porque a exposição solar regular,
contínua e moderada mantém níveis
adequados de vitamina D e ativa o
mecanismo de proteção e reparo do DNA.
É a exposição intermitente, como eu
falei, né? Se você ficar
intermitentemente exposto ao sol de
maneira intensa, que é típico, né, das
férias de quem vive dentro de
escritório, aí sim você se expõe a um
risco maior de cinoma basocelular,
tá? Então temos que cuidar da vitamina D
de dado, temos que cuidar da otimização
mitocondrial com enzima Q10, PQQ, nada
de mais alguns casos, antioxidantes,
vitamina C, zino, selena e gotationa,
tudo isso vai ajudar a prevenir o caso
base celular.
Então a combinação letal é deficiência
nutricional, disfunção mitocondrial,
exposição solar esporádica intensa,
tá? Então, pessoas que estão inflamadas,
intoxicadas com deficiências
nutricionais, função mitocondrial e vão
se expor ao sol de maneira intensa e
esporádica. Isso aí é a verdadeira causa
de epidemia do castoma na base celular.
Espero que tenha ficado claro aí.
Vamos para a próxima.
Vinagre de maçã
para ajudar na digestão e refluxo. Tem
alguma diferença entre tomar uma colher
na água ou em cápsulas?
Minha nutricionista recomendou na água,
porém minha preocupação seria de causar
mais dano ao esôfago. Comentei com ela,
ela receitou o mocosave. Não seria mais
fácil apenas tomar em cápsula?
Bem, a literatura científica mais
recente mostra que sim, tem uma
diferença significativa na
biodisponibilidade,
na eficácia entre as duas formas, porque
o vinagre líquido diluído em água tem
uma absorção mais rápida, é mais
completa desse ácido acético, que é o
componente ativo principal. Os estudos
estão demonstrando que quando você toma
o vinagre diluído, tem uma interação
direta com os receptores do isôfago e do
estômago, estimulando a produção do
mucoprotetor,
modulando a resposta asta de maneira
mais efetiva. As cápsulas, por outro
lado, precisam primeiro ser dissolvidas
e digeridas, o que resulta numa absorção
mais lenta e potencialmente menos
completa, além da dose menor, né? Um
estudo comparativo no jornal of
Nutritional Science Vitaminology
mostrou que as cápsulas podem não ser
tão eficazes quanto a forma líquida
controle do açúcar pós-pmandial e pós
alimentação e para os efeitos digestivos
imediatos.
Sobre essa preocupação com os danos ao
esôfago, ela é válida, mas vamos
contextualizar.
Quando o vinagre é de adequadamente
diluído, né, uma colher de sopa em 200 a
250 ml de água morna e tomado de 15 a 30
minutos antes das refeições, ele na
verdade pode ajudar a fortalecer o
esfíter esofágico inferior, que é a
válvula, né, que evita o refluxo e
reduziu o refluxo. A chave está na
diluição adequada e no timing correto.
Agora, sobreco, eu gosto desse produto.
Esse produto que a sua nutricionista
prescreveu é uma boa escolha. Ele é uma
combinação de polissacaridos
da palma forrageira com polifenóis das
folhas de oliveira. Tem estudos clínicos
duplos cegos demonstrando que essa
combinação forma uma camada protetora
na forma de gel sobre a mucosa esofágica
e gástrica funcionando como escudo
protetor. Então foi demonstrada uma
redução de 56 a 59%
nos sintomas de refluxo em estudos
controlados. Então, a minha
recomendação, continue com vinagre
líquido diluído, como a nutricionista
falou, mas faça assim, tome muosave
cerca de 20 minutos antes do vinagre.
Isso vai criar primeiro a camada
protetora e depois o vinagre diluído
poderá exercer seus efeitos benéficos
sem causar irritação. Então essa
combinação é interessante, é sinérgica e
oferece proteção dupla.
E as cápsulas de vinagre que você pode
utilizar em situações de emergência ou
quando tiver viajando,
porque aí seria mais conveniente, mas
perderia parte significativa dos
benefícios.
Se você tem dificuldade com o sabor do
vinagre de maçã, uma alternativa seria
tomar o vinagre diluído com o canudo
posicionado mais ao fundo da boca,
seguido de um enxague bucal para com
água, né, para você proteger o esmalte
dental.
Vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Doutor Alan, chá de eucalipto atrapalha
o sono. Quais as recomendações e o chá
de cideiro atrapalha?
O chá de eucalípto, ao contrário do que
se acredita popularmente, não atrapalha
o sono, tá? Pesquisas publicadas em 2024
na Frontiers em Pharmacology
demonstraram que o óleo essencial de
eucalipto tem efeito sedativo hipnótico.
Então o eucalipto aumenta os níveis de
neurotransmissores escalmantes ou
promotores do sono, o caso do gaba, da
glicina, do triptofano, do nacetil
serotonina e do 5HA
no cérebro. Então, estudos controlados,
o eucalipto melhorou a insônia em até
42% dos participantes.
Isso acontece porque eucalipto modula o
eixo intestino cérebro, aumenta a
diversidade da microbiota intestinal e
promove bactérias produtoras de ácidos
grásos de cadeia curta,
que por sua vez influenciam
positivamente os neurotransmissores
calmantes, né? Gabo, por exemplo,
quanto ao chá de cedreira, a milíça
oficinales é uma aliada do sono também.
Toma cuidado porque às vezes pode ter
confusões aí com as espécies. Então,
metaanálises recentes confirmam que a
cidreira reduz ansiedade em 18%, melhora
sintomas associados em 15% e diminui a
insônia impressionantes 42%. Então ela
age principalmente através da inibição
da GABA transaminase, aumentando a
disponibilidade do GABA no cérebro, que
é o principal neurotransmissor calmante.
Então, recomendações práticas pro chá de
eucalipto, uma xícara de cerca de 30
minutos antes de dormir pode ser
benéfica, especialmente se você tem
problemas respiratórios que atrapalham o
sono. Então, use folhas secas eucaliptos
globulos, cerca de 2 gem, 200 ml de água
quente, deixando infundir por 5 minutos.
E pro chá deva cidreira, a dose eficaz
seria de 1,5 a 3 g de folhas secas por
dia, dividido em duas doses. Então,
surgir uma xícara de 30 minutos após o
jantar e outra 30 minutos antes de
deitar.
Então, a cidra ter vantagem adicional de
não causar dependência.
Então, ambos o chá funcionam melhor
quando são usados regularmente por pelo
menos 15 dias, porque os efeitos são
cumulativos. OK,
vamos pra próxima.
Essa aqui eu vou deixar vocês lerem, tá?
Porque aqui é tá sem vírgula, tá sem
um monte de coisa aí, mas eu vou
responder sim,
mas dá um tempo vocês lerem a pergunta
aí.
Vamos lá.
Então, baseado nesse relato aí, o que
foi que aconteceu? Provavelmente uma
cosostocondrite clássica, né? Quando a
pessoa tem muitos espirros seguidos,
intensos, começa a machucar a
musculatura ali das costelas.
Então, a costaocondrite é uma inflamação
das cartilagens costais,
especificamente da junção cosstocondrais
ou coso externais. Então, esses pios
intensos e repetitivos vai causando
microtraumas machucados nessas
estruturas devido ao movimento
repetitivo e forçado da caixa torácica.
Então, cada vez que você espirrava
forte, suas costelas se expandiam
violentamente. Isso causou inflamando,
causou inflamação nas cartilagens.
Sobre as gotículas de sangue. Isso foi
resultado de pequenos vasos sanguíneos
que se romperam na mucosa nasal devido à
força dos espirros. É que nós chamamos
de epistáxe menor, algo completamente
esperado após espiros muito intensos e
repetitivos.
E o fato de ter acontecido apenas uma
vez e ser quase imperceptível
confirma que foi apenas um trauma
mecânico local temporário e não tem
maiores implicações. A dor que você
sente há três semanas, que piora quando
aperta o local, respira profundamente ou
muda de posição, é bem típica da costa.
E a literatura médica mais recente
confirma que essa condição pode
persistir por várias semanas ou até
meses em alguns casos. Então, portanto,
portanto, é importante destacar que ela
é completamente benigna, autolimitada.
Então, você pode usar, se for poucos
dias de dor mais intensa,
antiinflamatórios comuns mesmo, não
esteroidais, alguprofena, por exemplo,
mas não passe aí de uma semana de uso.
Depois, se tiver que continuar tomando
antiinflamatório, tome cucumina ou
bozuela ferrata ou garra do diabo ou
canela de velho ou pé, tá? Um desses
antiflamatórios naturais. Depois você
pode também aplicar calor local moderado
na região afetada 15 a 20 minutos, três
a quatro vezes ao dia. Então calor local
ajuda a relaxar a musculatura e melhorar
a circulação e evite movimentos bruscos
e atividades que vão piorar a dor
durante as próximas duas semanas. Então
isso inclui exercícios de membros
superiores e movimento de torção do
tronco
e considere magnésio bisglicinato que
vai ajudar a relaxar a musculatura.
Vitamina D de dado 3 também vai ajudar
porque ajuda na recuperação do tecido
cartilagenoso.
Se a dor ficar muito persistente após
duas semanas de tratamento, pode pensar
em orar um ortopedista e fazer uma
infiltração local com corticode. Mas
isso é raramente necessário e eu
recomendo só em casos assim de dor muito
intensa mesmo.
Então não é nada grave, tá, pelo que
você tá falando, mas obviamente tem que
fazer uma consulta médica se você quiser
ter certeza, tá?
E aparentemente não
representa um risco maior a sua saúde,
cardiovascular ou pulmonar.
E a radiografia, nesse caso não é
necessária, geralmente, tá? Eu
diagnóstico postocondrite é clínico. OK.
Próxima pergunta.
Esse que eu vou deixar deixar vocês
lerem também.
Bem, vamos lá.
Presença de pus no curativo. Isso é
preocupante, isso é sinal de uma
infecção e requer atenção. Sim, a
literatura mais recente confirma que
pacientes diabéticos tipo dois tem risco
de dois a cinco vezes maior desenvolver
infecções pós-cirúrgicas.
Então, a de pulsos indica infecção do
sítio cirúrgico, né? E no contexto do
diabetes controlado, pode evoluir de
maneira rápida e até fatal em alguns
casos. Então é essencial que seja feita
cultura da secreção para identificar que
bicho tá crescendo e ajudar o
antibiótico necessário. Então procure a
assistência médica.
Sobre a afirmação da médica de que o
osso cicatriza mesmo com o diabético
controlado. Tecnicamente sim o osso pode
cicatrizar, mas a consolação óssea é
menor, é significativamente prejudicada.
Então, a hiperglicemia crônica reduz a
atividade das células que fazem osso,
né, os osteoblastos, aumenta o estresse
oxidativo, prejudica a formação de
colágeno e compromete a vascularização
do tecido ósseo. O tempo de consolidação
pode ser até três vezes maior em
diabéticos controlados. Então, para para
acelerar a cicatrização, minha
recomendação é vitamina D, vitamina K2,
tá? manter níveis adequados. Aí vitamina
D de 5.000 a 10.000 100 por dia.
Vitamina K2 100 a 200 microg por dia.
Vocês lembram que o K2 direciona o
cálcio pros ossos, né, e tira o cálcio
da tecidos moles das artérias, o cálcio
citrato, o magnésio, glicinato, a
vitamina C,
importante também como antioxidante para
cí colágeno, o zinco, se for necessário,
o colágeno hidrolizado ajuda na
cicatrização também.
E o cobre se for também indicado.
Silício orgânico ajuda também
outras coisas que podem ajudar
MSM, ôga-3,
curcumina, tá? E importante controlar
esse diabetes o má o máximo possível.
Então, a dieta antiflamatória, né,
cortando açúcar, farinha, alimentos
processados, industrializados, é
fundamental também cortar glúten
laticínios.
Proteína de alta qualidade em cada
refeição, pelo menos 1,2 g por kilo de
peso corporal ao dia.
E considerar oxigênio hiperbárico se
tiver disponível, que ajuda muito na
cicatrização de feridas difíceis, tá?
Especialmente diabéticos.
A próxima.
Dr. Alan, eu pedi cúrcuma 500 mg, veio
longa. A cúrcuma,
o nome oficial da cúrcuma é cúrcuma
longa, tá? Não sei se você sabia disso,
né? Mas é cúrcuma longa, não da planta.
Mas vamos lá. Qual é a cúrcuma que eu
recomendo?
Eh, eu recomendo uma cúma de alta
absorção. Aí no mercado da farmácia
magistral no Brasil tem o curcovil, tem
o curicel
e tem o Kurit. Eu vou colocar aqui no
chat para vocês verem, tá?
E vou pôr na tela marcas de curcumina de
absorção,
melhor porque são micronizadas, tá?
Vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Jovem de 28 anos, com déficit de atenção
severa, não consegue se concentrar na
leitura e muito ansioso, não sabe se é
autismo ou déficit mesmo. Quais são as
dicas? Tem algumas perguntas, pessoal,
que tá se repetindo de uma live para
outra. O meu palpite é que a pessoa tá
deixando a pergunta, não assiste ao
vivo, não assiste também depois e volta
a fazer a pergunta depois na semana
seguinte. Então peço a vocês que mesmo
que vocês não assistam ao vivo, dá uma
olhada nas lives anteriores para não
ficar repetindo a mesma pergunta todas
as lives, tá? Porque esse caso aí já
teve umas três ou quatro semanas com
essa pergunta aí de da pessoa que talvez
tenha TDAH, que talvez tenha autismo,
que talvez tenha esquizofrenia, mas
vamos responder porque tem gente nova
aqui no grupo.
Vamos falar de novo da diferença entre
TDAH e autismo.
Existe sobreposição, sim. Eu tive num
evento essa semana inclusive que eu
fiquei vendo
foi a semana passada, na verdade esse
evento, que alguns casos esquisoides, ou
seja, que são casos que lembram
esquizofrenia, tem autismo junto, tá?
Então existe hoje bem caracterizado o
autismo esquisoide, tá? Uma coisa que eu
não sabia, aprendi esses dias agora.
O TDAH severo e autismo de alto
funcionamento podem realmente se
sobrepor em alguns sintomas.
Os estudos recentes mostram que 20 a 37%
dos adultos com uma condição que também,
desculpa, 20 a 30% dos 20 a 30% dos 37%
dos adultos t as duas condições em
conjunto, tá?
Então, no TDH, o problema principal está
na tensão, na hiperatividade e na
impulsividade. Lembra dessas três
coisas? Atenção, hiperatividade,
impulsividade. OK? De novo, atenção,
hiperatividade e impulsividade. Já no
autismo, as dificuldades são de
comunicação social e padrões repetitivos
de comportamento,
tá? Então, autismo, problema de
comunicação social, padrão repetitivo de
comportamento. Então, a ansiedade
intensa que você descreve pode acontecer
em ambas as condições e pode piorar o
sintomas de desatenção.
Então, na minha experiência, eu sempre
começo investigando deficiências
nutricionais.
Os pacientes com TDH geralmente tem
déficit de magnésio, então é bom você
repor 400 a 600 mg de magnésio,
glicinato ou treonato,
preferencialmente à noite, que vai
ajudar no sono e ansiedade. E o magnésio
tronato vocês sabem, atravessa a
barreira hematocefálica e vai entrar no
cérebro com mais facilidade e vai
aumentar muito mais níveis cerebrais de
magnésio. A vitamina D é um pilar
fundamental. Temos que manter no sangue
entre 40 e 70 e o que vai exigir uma
suplementação diária entre 5.000 a
10.000 unidades por dia, sempre com K2.
Ô3 de alta qualidade, pelo menos 2 g por
dia de EPA e DH combinados, vai ajudar
na função dos neurônios.
As vitaminas do complexo do B são
importantes também, especialmente a B6
na forma de peridoxal ciclo fosfato,
B12, meticobalamina e metiofolato, que é
a B9, né? Então são cruciais paraa
produção de neurotransmissores.
O lítio nutricional, quer dizer, o lítio
orotato no Brasil, infelizmente a gente
não acha sem ser importado
10 mg por dia, de 5 a 20 mg por dia. É
excelente para esses casos também de
TDH. ajuda bastante a
ajuda bastante a
estabelecer, né, estabelecer, não,
estabilizar, né, a parte emocional.
Então, estamos falando de doses
nutricionais,
então, né, para confundir com o lítio,
carbonato de lítio, né, que é utilizado
nas doenças psiquiátricas.
Então, tem uma técnica muito
interessante de memorização que é bom
para ansiedade foco, que é a técnica de
pomodoro adaptada.
Então, você pode fazer sessões de 15
minutos de foco total, seguidas de 5
minutos de pausa e durante as pausas
fazer exercício de piração profunda,
expirar por 4 segundos, segurar por
quatro, expirar por seis, tá? Inspire
por 4 segundos, segure por quatro,
expire por seis. Isso ativa o sistema
nervoso parassimpático e reduz
ansiedade. Meditação mindfulness é muito
importante para TDAH.
Exercício físico 30 minutos diários
intenso é muito bom para controlar a
ansiedade também. Então, treino de força
ou treinos hit, né, que é high intensity
interval training ajuda bastante para
aumentar dopamina cerebral e
noreprinefrina para ajudar no TDAH,
eliminar o glúteo em laticínios
porque eles são inflamatórias por causa
inflamação cerebral,
especialmente pessoas sensíveis
investigar metais pesados através de um
teste de provocação com DMSA,
né? né? Então, fazer esses testes na
urina depois da provocação
e pode ter necessário fazer, pode ser
necessário fazer aquelação.
Beleza, vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Doutor Alan, uma pessoa vai se consultar
comigo, né? Pode ser via internet, sim,
a gente tem consultas online. Quais são
os valores atuais? Eu não vou falar
aqui, tá? Eh, mas eu vou te passar o
telefone paraa secretária, tá? Qual é a
quantidade de exames que geralmente eu
passo? Eu não eu nem sei o número exato,
tá? Eu nós temos aqui os exames, mas
pode variar de caso a caso e mas os
convênios geralmente cobrem,
sendo que pela internet não é possível
analisar fisicamente, então urológico tá
escapado. Não, não dá para fazer toque,
obviamente, né? Mas você pode fazer
exames de laboratoriais de imagem, tá?
Então, deixa eu colocar aqui o telefone
do WhatsApp
da secretária, tá?
Deixa eu achar aquiinho
só.
Pronto. Esse aqui é o telefone que fala
direto com a secretária.
Vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Mulher de 54 anos diabética que quebrou
o osso do braço da pergunta anterior. Às
vezes sente dor, o que significa dor? Já
faz um mês e meio que ela fez a
cirurgia. Crcuma substituinte promatório
de farmácia.
Depende. Para dor aguda não substitui
porque não é tão intenso.
Na literatura científica recente, a
cúrcuma é eficaz na redução da dor
pós-operatória inflamatória.
Alguns estudos falam que tem eficácia
comparável aos antiinflamatórios não
esteroidais, né, tipo ibuprofeno.
Mas eu não contaria com isso. Na
prática, eu vejo que não é tão potente.
Uma metaanálise de 2021 que teve 1258
1258 pacientes demonstrou que os
curcuminides, né, que são as substâncias
da cúrcuma, foram simfativamente mais
eficazes que os antiinflamatórios na
redução da dor e com menos efeitos
colaterais. Eu diria que na prática é os
efeitos colaterais que faz uma
diferença.
Então, paraa cúrcuma ser efetiva como
substituto de antiinflamatórios
convencionais, a dosagem é muito
importante. Então você tem que, se você
for usar uma cumina normal assim, que
não é de alta absorção, né, aquelas
micronizadas, né, que são e nanomicelas,
aí você vai ter que utilizar 500 a 1 g,
duas a três vezes ao dia junto com a
pimenta preta para aumentar a absorção,
né, a biopiperina.
O problema é que a cúrcuma tem absorção
muito baixa, né? Então você tem que
utilizar a pimenta preta nesses casos
para aumentar absorção, ou melhor ainda
utilizar uma cucumina de alta absorção.
O óleo de coco também ajuda na absorção
da curcumina, tá?
E pro diabético, a cúrcuma tem vantagens
adicionais. Então, estudos mostram
melhora na sensibilidade insulina,
redução da neuropatia diabética e
proteção contra complicações vasculares.
Teve o estudo de 2023 que mostrou que a
combinação de curcumina com glicasida,
né, que é um remédio para diabetes, anti
diabético, né, hipoglicemiante oral,
melhorou significativamente os
marcadores de neuropatia diabética.
E você pode utilizar também a bozuela
serrata, que é o outro inflamatório
muito bom, natural, que é rico emba, né,
que é ácido bozuélico,
que inibe uma via inflamatória
importante.
Ômega-3 de alta concentração também tem
efeito antiinflamatório,
tem o pea, tem o canela de velho,
tem o
garra do diabo, tem o MSM, são todos
antiinflamatórios naturais bem
interessantes.
Agora, no caso de uma dor aguda, como eu
falei, aí se for usar por poucos dias, é
melhor utilizar um antiinflamatório
farmacêutico, um emboprofeno, um
diclofenáco, porque vai ter uma ação
mais rápida e potente.
Só que não pode ser utilizado por muito
tempo, senão vai ter lesão renal, vai
dar úero no estômago, pode afetar o
próprio fígado, pode afetar o coração,
pode piorar a cicatrização óssea se usar
há muito tempo, tá? Então é muito
importante tomar cuidado com isso.
Bem, vamos pra próxima.
Exames de sangue podem identificar a
pedra nos rins ou apenas problemas de
falência em si? Não. O exame de sangue
não vai mostrar a pedra no rim de
maneira direta, não, tá? Eles vai ele
vai identificar fatores relacionados às
pedras dos ins, né? Não vai ver a pedra
de maneira direta.
Então que exames são esses, né? Você vê
o cálcio na urina, o cálcio no sangue.
Pessoas têm cálcio urinário aumentado e
no sangue pode ter hiperparatiroidismo
primário, que é uma causa importante de
cálculos urinários de repetição.
Então, paratormônio aumentado no sangue
indicativo de hiperparatiroidismo.
É importante também avaliar esse
hormônio PTH.
O ácido úrico também é importante. Tem
pessoas que têm gota aí, vai ter muito
ácido úrico na urina e vai aumentar a
formação de algumas pedras.
O ácido úrico alto também ajuda a formar
cálculos de oxalato de cálcio através de
um processo chamado nucleação. Então não
é só pedra de ácido úrico, também pode
aumentar a formação de pedra de oxalado
de cálcio.
A gente pede o exame de de função renal
que é edição de sangue, caratilina,
urea, a cistatina C. Existe um cálculo
que é feito com aureia e creatinina que
é a taxa de filtração glomerular
glomerular estimada.
Exame de urina também importante para
ver se não tem infecção.
O exame de uras vai ver a questão do
cálcio, do oxalato, do citrato, do ácido
úrico, do fósforo, do sódio, que se de
alteração nesses valores aí pode
aumentar o risco de pedras futuras.
Por exemplo, cálcio aumentado na urina
ou sódio aumentado na urina, o oxalato
aumentado na urina aumenta o risco de
pedras no futuro. O citrato aumentado é
protetor, o magnésio aumentado é
protetor.
O ácido úrico também aumentado é
indicativo de risco de formação de
pedras.
Os aspectos mais comuns são oxalato
aumentado, cálcio aumentado e citrato
diminuído na urina.
Então é importante você usar citrato de
potássio e citrato de magnésio para
prevenir a formação de pedras nos ins.
Já que o citrato ele é um inibidor
natural da cristalização. O magnésio é
outro. Por isso que é bom se trata de
potássio, mas se trata de magnésio.
Além dos exames de sangue, você pode
pedir também relação à bumina creatinina
urinária, né, que é para ver se a pessoa
tá expirindo a albumina na urina, que é
sinal de lesão renal.
E tem muitos pacientes que têm pedras
que tm função renal completamente
normal.
Pessoa que tem histórico de pedra nos
tem que tomar muita água, 2,5 m por dia,
cortar o sal refinado,
cortar alimentos processados
industrializados
e fazer o perfil metabólico completo que
eu mencionei aqui de 24 horas para ver o
risco de recidiva. Tem casos, por
exemplo, de pacientes que tem que tomar,
além do citrato de potássio e magnésio,
tomar diuréticos tiasídicos para
diminuir aí a excreção na urina de
cálcio ou mesmo alopinal que vai
diminuir o ácido úrico.
OK? Vamos pra próxima.
Surgiu nova possibilidade de tratamento
de cura do Alzheimer, autismo ou
esquizofrenia ou déficit de atenção?
Essa pergunta tá repetida, pessoal.
Então, vou pular, tá? A resposta rápida
é não. Eu já respondi essa pergunta numa
live anterior. Eu acho que a pessoa
colocou de novo porque não assistiu.
Isso aqui eu vou deixar vocês lerem.
Bem, pessoal, é um mito antigo que tomar
banho com água morna ou lavar as mãos
com água aquecida pelo sol vai causar ou
piorar gripe, tá? Gripes refriados são
causados pelo vírus com uma pessoa com
sistema imune um pouco comprometido e
não por mudança de temperatura. Então, o
vírus precisa entrar em contato com
mucosa para infectar e precisa e a
pessoa precisa estar com o sistema imune
um pouquinho debilitado.
Então, não tem nenhum problema em tomar
banho com água na temperatura que
preferir com tanto que não seja quente
demais. E a água morna vai ser benéfica
para relaxar a musculatura e aliviar
sintomas quando a pessoa tá gripada.
Já falei várias vezes aqui sobre
tratamento de gripe, né, pela visão
integrativa funcional, né, mas eh você
pode usar limão, alho, mel, vitamina C
em altas doses,
né, usar 2 g de vitamina C a cada 4
horas até melhorar ou até dar diarreia
para isso é muito bom para encurtar a
gripe.
O alho ajuda, o limão ajuda.
O alho tem propriedades anti,
né, microbianas, né, bem interessante. O
própolis verde é muito bom, 500 mg duas
vezes ao dia.
Se tiver com zinco baixo, é bom também
repor zinco. A quecetina ajuda a fazer o
zinco entrar dentro da célula ser
antiinflamatório e antiinflamatório
antistamínico natural. Então a quecetina
vai ajudar po zinco para dentro da
célula e melhorar a função imune. Tem
também ter uma ação antiviral aqucetina.
O nac que ajuda a fluidificar as
secreções e aumenta também a gluta que é
antioxidante, a vitamina D que eu já
comentei várias vezes aqui.
Selênio também, se tiver com deficiência
de selênio, vitamina A por três dias
pode ajudar. Melatonina de 6 a 10 mg na
hora de dormir. Veja, veja que a dose é
mais alta do que a dose para dormir, tá?
6 a 10 mg, dose alta, mas é pela ação
imunomoduladora e antiformatória.
Um chá de gengibre fresco com cucúcoma
pode ajudar. Gagarejos com água e sal
podem ajudar. Inalação com vapor pode
ajudar manter-se bem hidratado. OK?
Gripe forte que demora a passar e tem
tosse muito forte, repetitiva, sem muito
catar. O remédio natural, se bem feito,
pode cortar sim. Então não vou responder
essa aqui porque acabei de responder é
bem parecido com a pergunta anterior,
né, que nem eu falei agora a pouco.
Então é só voltar o vídeo e ver o que eu
já falei sobre a questão do tratamento
aí da gripe. OK? Então vou pular essa
aqui.
Ah, só um detalhe. Se a tosse persistir
por mais de 8 semanas
ou se a febre vier persistente ou com
sangue no escarro ou piora progressiva
com peso de peso, aí tem que investigar
outras causas como qualquer lucho,
tuberculose ou refluxo, tá?
Beber água quente sem ser pelo fogo,
mas em temperatura ambiente pode dar
gripe? Não, não vai dar gripe não, tá?
Eh, isso aí é mito, tá? Acabei de falar
sobre isso.
Não tem nenhuma comprovação científica
que relaciona o consumo de água fria ou
temperatura ambiente com infecções
respiratórias.
Agora sim, quando você tá gripado,
bebidas quentes podem sim proporcionar
um alívio sintomático, né, mais do que
bebidas em temperatura ambiente.
Importante se manter hidratado
independente da temperatura da água.
Isso aqui também bem longa essa pergunta
aqui. Vou deixar vocês lerem.
Bem, a nós sabemos que a fibromialgia é
um problema mitocondrial essencialmente,
né? Então, esses elementos e alfa
alipoico,
carnitina,
o biquinol, todos eles ajudam pqq porque
são agentes que vão melhorar a função
mitocondrial, certo?
Essa combinação que você colocou é uma
boa combinação,
especialmente aí a carnitina, o
ófalipoico e o pq e o bquinol, que é a
forma mais ativa da da coenzima.
Fibromialgia é uma condição muito
difícil de tratar.
Tem estudos mostrando que passa com
fibrgia tem níveis de conhecis reduzidos
em 40 a 50% do normal.
Ou seja, eles têm disfunção mitocondrial
significativa.
Então, além do que você colocou aí, né,
o biquinol, carnitina, alfalipoico,
omôme3, o e nac, vitamina D, PQQ,
você pode pensar também derribose,
5 g, três vezes ao dia,
que também vai ajudar a aumentar a TP
muscular.
Não sei se você colocou magnésio aí, mas
magnésio, glicinato malato, malato
melhor ainda. Mitocôndria seria bom.
Vitaminas do complexo B, selênio, que
trabalha cineticamente com enzima Q10,
melhorando a função mitocondrial.
Os melhores horários é alo e carnitina,
né? falipoico e carnitina pela manhã em
jejum ou 30 minutos antes das refeições.
Derribosa pode dividir em três doses ao
longo do dia. Com enzima Q10 qualquer
horário é possível, mas é bom que você
consuma com gorduras para aumentar a
absorção e o magnésio melhor horário à
noite e evitar de usar o alfalipoico com
a biotina juntos porque pode ter
competição pela absorção.
também separar o ferro do alfalipoico
por duas horas, porque o alfalipoico
pode quear o ferro, né? Ou seja, não
deixar o ferro entrar e não tomar coisa
maquia muito próximo do horário de
dormir, porque pode dar agitação e sono
em algumas pessoas.
Sobre a preocupação da exagero, né, do
exagero de antioxidante, você pode fazer
a seguinte otimização.
Segunda, quarta e sexta, você pode usar
alfalipoico, carnitina com enzima Q10 ou
biquinol, mais a vitamina D de 5000 e
ômega-3. Na terça e quinta usar o NAC,
PQQ, a vitamina C, hipossomal, ô3, a
vitamina D. e não sábado, domingo, usar
o blend de visão, ômega-3, vitamina D e
co enzima que é 10.
Se você treinar, lembra que o NC
vitamina C, se você tomar logo depois do
exercício, pode reduzir adaptações, que
caso você queira hipertrofia, então
melhor tu usar nos dias alternados do
exercício ou pelo menos 4 horas distante
do exercício.
PqQ com enema Q10 trabalham melhor
juntos.
Mas o PQQ pode ser usado em dias
alternados sem problemas. E a vitamina D
também pode ser feito os outros dias
alternados
e omega3 é melhor usar diariamente.
Tomar muito cuidado com o ferro, tá?
Porque doses excessiva de ferro aumenta
o estresse oxidativo.
Cuidado com o excesso de cálcio. Tem o
contrabalanço do magnésio, que pode dar
problema também.
Beleza,
vamos pro próximo.
Erra Baliira também é boa? Sim, Rinaldo.
Boa
dica.
Cara, eu não consigo comer e fazer
musculação logo em seguida. Eliseu, eu
sugiro que você faça musculação pelo
menos 4 horas depois de comer. Ainda
acho pouco. Muitas vezes eu fico de
jejumas 6 horas antes de fazer. senão
ficou tendo refluxo.
Sim, sim. Essa é uma boa estratégia,
Eliseu.
Não vejo problema nenhum que tem
esclerose múltipla ou sistêmica usar a
progesterona, tá?
Boa noite a todos que não dei boa noite
ainda.
Enild, tem vídeo sobre isso no canal,
né? As tachantinas e achantina luteína,
basicamente ômega-3 e os antioxidantes
que você conseguir dar além dos
polivitamínicos. Tá
bem? Estamos quase no fim das perguntas.
Vamos lá.
Gostaria de saber como aumentar minha
testosterona.
Tem vídeo sobre isso no canal, vídeo na
parte aberta do canal, tá?
Que que é importante pra vitamina,
desculpa, pra testosterona?
Zinco é muito importante, vitamina D é
muito importante
para modular a testosterona. Então tem
que manter a vitamina D entre 40 e 60 no
sangue, né?
Para isso, como eu já falei, tem que ter
tem que tem que ser entre 5.000 a 10.000
por dia.
Magnésio também trabalha junto com a
vitamina D e o zinco. Então é importante
você manter o magnésio adequado paraa
testosterona. Exercício físico de força
é muito importante,
tá? Para você modular a testosterona.
Jejum ajuda também dormir bem ajuda
bastante a você aumentar testosterona.
Exercícios hit, né? Ou seja, com
intensidade alta, alternado com
intensidade baixa também aumenta a
testosterona.
Uma forma de achagana chamada KS KSM6
ajuda também,
aumenta de 15 a 20% aí o nível de
testosterona.
O feno grego tem resultados consistentes
também, 500 a 600 mg de extrato
padronizado diário.
E é muito importante também controlar a
gordura corporal, porque a gordura
abdominal ela vai converter
essos em estradiol através da aromatase.
Então é muito importante perder gordura
visceral especialmente, mais gordura em
geral.
Então o jejum vai ajudar a aentar a
testosterona, mas não faça jejum
prolongado demais, tá? Porque pode
aumentar o cortisol pelo estresse. Então
não passe de 16 horas de jejum. Fareia
entre 12 a 16 horas de jejum para ajudar
na testosterona.
Reduza o consumo de álcool porque reduz
a testosterona também.
aumenta a conversão de testosterona para
estrogênio
e elimine os alimentos inflamatórios.
Pronto,
última pergunta.
Para o DMRI, pode usar também o tenante
biomodulador?
Sim, sim. Boa contribuição.
Já temos mais de uma hora de live,
pessoal. E que acontece
isso? Eu pedi para não fazer porque tava
muito longa a lista de perguntas.
Se eu fico muito mais de uma hora aqui,
além de eu ficar cansado, vocês não vão
assistir a live depois, né? vocês não
vão assistir o vídeo gravado, aí as
perguntas vão ser repetidas, né, como
aconteceu já várias vezes.
Bem, pessoal, alguém que está ao vivo
aqui que fez pergunta do questionário,
quer alguma clarificação, alguma
clarificação extra, alguma coisa que eu
falei que não ficou claro? Eu vou dar
mais uns 2 minutos e vou encerrar aqui,
tá?
que eu tenho que ir paraa academia hoje
ainda fazer meu aeróbico, porque ontem
eu fiz um treino pesado de musculação,
então hoje vou fazer só aeróbico.
Muito obrigado, Reinaldo, pelo
comentário.
Se vocês tiverem sugestões de mudança de
modelo da live dos apoiadores, eu tô
todo ouvido, tá? Hoje tem pessoas novas
aí que entraram no grupo e caso vocês
queiram dar sugestões, a gente pode
estudar mudança de formato, né?
Porque assim, eu quero ser o mais
democrático possível, responder as
perguntas que vocês me mandam, tá? A
minha preocupação é que algumas
perguntas podem ser muito, muito
específicas
e não estarem
cobrindo a necessidade do grupo como um
todo. Então eu não quero ser
seletivo demais e tirar algumas
perguntas, porque eu acho que é até
chato com a pergunta que com a pessoa
que fez a pergunta, mas por outro lado
também não quero aborrecer as pessoas
que acham pergunta inócoa ou que não faz
sentido, entendeu? Então eu queria
tentar entrar no equilíbrio aí entre
tentar responder o máximo de pergunta
possível sem aborrecer os outros, né?
Então a gente
pode trocar ideia sobre isso também.
E tá falando que o formato tá bom.
Obrigado, Reinaldo.
Agradeço aí os comentários, viu?
Aí quando der 1:11 eu vou sair, tá?
Alguém que está ao vivo tem alguma
dúvida das perguntas que foram
respondidas?
Eu sei que é muito volume de informação.
É interessante vocês depois assistirem
com calma depois.
Enildo, se eu não me engano, tá até um
documento sobre isso daí.
Tem um item lá no documento que vocês
têm acesso sobre degeneração macular.
Muita luz para todos nós. Sim, Rinaldo,
com certeza.
Bem, pessoal, muito obrigado aí pela
participação de vocês,
os novos
membros aí do grupo, sejam muito
bem-vindos. É um prazer estar aqui com
vocês e vamos nos falando aí,
nos vemos na live da semana que vem.
Até a próxima, pessoal.
Não